. Also, wir sind das, ich finde immer noch, wir müssen erklären, dass wir sind, wir sind das Podcast-Ovo. Weißt du, das hasse ich an dir. Deswegen finde ich, dass du so ein richtiges widerliches Arschloch bist, weil du so ein Overachiever bist. Du willst immer alle Häkchen haben, du willst immer alle Aufträge führen. Ich werde da so ein Video spielen, bist du so jemand, der alle Sidequests macht. Nein, es ist nicht nur wichtig, die Prinzessin zu retten, dem armen Bauer auf dem Feld muss auch geholfen werden. Weil man dann nämlich in der Hauptstory, man hat schon mehr Taler gesammelt, man hat schon mehr Credits gesammelt, ich finde es gut, dass du jetzt auch nicht aufs Handy geguckt hast oder so. Nein, aber du bist so ein richtiger Streber und Leute hassen Streber. Aber Leute lieben mich. Na gut, entweder bricht das Universum hier gerade zusammen oder es stimmt nicht. Ich sage mal, nein, du möchtest ja auch erfolgreich und interessant werden, so wie ich. Und da kann ich dir nur eine Sache raten, vermeide Dinge, die alle Leute hassen. Was alle Leute hassen, sind Streber und sind Leute, die gut aussehen. Und Besserwisser. Und Besserwisser. Also, man muss scheiße aussehen,
Leuten durchgehen lassen, wenn sie wie statt als benutzen, einzigste sagen und zumindestens. Und auf statt offen. Genau. Und manchmal auch mal schludrig sein und sagen, scheiß doch jetzt auf diesen dreckigen Bauern, der seine Hühner verloren hat. Ich habe nur Angst, dass wir Leute nicht mit ins Boot ziehen gerade. Wir sind nämlich dann Inselkinder. Aber dafür haben wir doch unsere Traktorstrahlen, denn wir sind ein Ufo. Ich finde, du machst das richtig gut. Das war jetzt noch ein bisschen der Raucherhust mit drin. Meine Stimme ist ein bisschen belegt heute. Salz, Pfeffer, Pfeffer, Salz, das Podcast Ufo hebt ab mit seinem Traktorstrahl. Ich glaube nicht, was der Fall ist. Das Problem an Rappen ist, dass es so schnell ist. Ich kann es einfach nicht. Es ist nicht weit weg von Impro-Comedy-Rap, Freestyle. Du musst ja auch schnell ein gutes, assoziatives Gedächtnis haben. Ja. Vielen Dank, Herr Besserwisser. Es fängt schon wieder so an. Alter, wenn du deine Brille noch aufsetzt und gut aussiehst, dann hast du ein riesiges Problem. Ich sehe mit der Brille besser aus. 20 Fragen an Stefan Titzel, Titzel, Titzel, Titzel, Titzel, Titzel. Stefan, was ist dein grösster Traum? Ich werde gerade in einer Gruppe angesprochen. Um in einer WhatsApp-Gruppe angesprochen zu werden, ist für mich immer so ein Riesending, weil es fällt mir erst so Monate danach auf und man kann nicht mehr antworten, weil die Gesprächsteuer wieder in eine ganz andere Richtung ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite macht man sich auch rar. Ich mag ja die Leute, die in der Gruppenkonversation schon ewig lang drin sind und erst so nach zwei Wochen überhaupt erst mal antworten. Da denkt man sich, oh, okay. Das sind die coolen Kids, das sind auch die, die zu spät auf ein Party ankommen. Und das habe ich nämlich, ich habe nämlich mal eine Studie durchgeführt, dass man zu spät zu Partys kommen soll. Das ist natürlich ganz verbreitet eigentlich. Und dann wollte ich es dann mal einführen, um zu spät zu beides zu kommen, um cool zu sein. Aber dann kam ich zu spät. Und du musst mich genau den Punkt abwischen, abstecken. Ich bin super. Ich verspreche mich nicht mehr. Abjälte, verspreche ich mich nicht mehr. Das macht dich real. Nehmen wir schon auf eigentlich. Nee, nee. Die Antworten werden doch immer skandinavischer. Nee. Ich glaube nämlich auch, dass so skandinavische Sprachen irgendwie von Deutsch abstammen. Deutsche, die sehr schludrig reden, reden irgendwann Dänisch. Ich liebe es, dass du deine Glaubenssätze formulierst zu Fakten. Ich glaube, dass das Chinesische verwandt ist mit dem Deutschen, einfach Glaubenssachen, die einfach nicht stimmen. Ich glaube, 18 ist grösser als 30. Aber Spaß beiseite. Genau, jetzt mal Spaß beiseite. Erst mal, wir haben gelesen, nehmen wir schon auf eigentlich, muss ich jetzt erklären, was ich sage, muss ich die Leute mit ins Boot nehmen. Ja, du musst das erklären. Spaß beiseite, wir haben gelesen, da hat jemand keinen Gag gemacht, hat dann geschrieben, aber jetzt Spaß beiseite, hat dann was Ernstes geschrieben, was natürlich sehr clever ist, weil das vorherige Gesagte so aussehen lässt, ist, ob es unglaublich lustig gewesen wäre. Die Leutensinnig schlechtes Gewissen. Das heisst, sobald du sagst nach einer langweiligen Rede Spaß beiseite denken, ach das war alles ein Gag. Super, der muss, habe ich nicht verstanden, der muss unglaublich schlau gewinnen sein. Das fangen die Leute automatisch anzulachen, ja. Wir reden immer durcheinander, glaube ich. Das ist okay, das ist dynamisch, das ist jugendlich, frisch, spritzig, wir wollen uns auch ein bisschen abheben. Und es ist nicht perfekt, es macht uns sympathisch. Wir wollen uns ja auch ein bisschen abheben. Nein, die Sache ist ja die. Ich kann jetzt nicht darauf antworten. Vor allem, ich wusste auch gerade nicht, was ich sagen sollte, deswegen habe ich angefangen mit die Sache ist ja die. Kommen wir zurück zu der ersten Frage an Stefan Titzel. Was ist dein grösster Traum? Mein grösster, das ist auch so ein Ding, ich will einfach schweigen, wenn ich Zeit nicht will. Mein grösster Traum ist, dass alle Menschen, außer mir selbst, dass alle Menschen dicker sind. Also dass alle anderen Menschen außer dir so 20 Kilo zunehmen. Ja, genau. Das ist ein großer Traum. Und dass meine Figur, die ist nicht perfekt, ein Schönheitsideal wird in dieser Welt. Und könntest nicht einfach du schöner werden? Nee, nee, das wäre zu einfach. Und ich finde es auch gar nicht so schlecht, nicht dünn und nicht dick zu sein, so ein Mittending zu sein, ist nicht schlecht. Aber wenn das das Schönheitsideal wäre, wäre halt perfekt, das wäre für alle am einfachsten. Und dass Leute dann sagen, auch Stars, wo man jetzt denkt, oh fuck, ich würde gern so aussehen, dass die sagen, fuck, ich würde gern so aussehen wie Stefan. Das wäre so ein Ziel für mich. Aber meinst du, würden die dann sagen, ne, nein, die werden mich ja nicht kennen. Auch in der Welt würden die mich nicht kennen. Das wäre aber auch gar nicht schlimm. Was glaubst du, sagt Brad Pitt, ich würde gern so aussehen wie? Glaubst du, es gibt jemanden, oder so die Leute, die wir als hässliche Leute, als schön empfinden, glaubst du, es gibt Leute, die ihn noch schöner finden? Hör auf mich da rein, mit ins Boot zu holen. Also ich finde, ich habe dich gerade gefragt, was sein grösster Wunsch ist. Ich habe nicht mit meinem Aussehen abgeschlossen. Ich habe dich gerade gefragt, was sein grösster Wunsch ist, und du hast gesagt, ich möchte in Relation zu anderen besser aussehen. Da muss doch irgendwo ein kleines Minderwertigkeitskomplexchen irgendwo versteckt sein, oder? Das glaube ich doch schon. Ich glaube, dass Brad Pitt, um auf die Frage mal zu antworten, keinen hat. Glaubst du wirklich, dass Brad Pitt sagt, ich bin der schönste Mann der Welt? Wenn ich den sehe, wie er seine Sonnenbrille aufsetzt, dann glaube ich, dass er sehr zufrieden mit sich selber ist. Sonnenbrille sind so ein Ding. Da wirst du sofort skeptisch. Warum ist er so selbstzufrieden? Leute mit selbst Sonnenbrillen sind so ein Ding, die Leute auch ... Da wirst du sofort skeptisch. Warum ist der so selbstzufrieden?
Leute mit Sonnenbrille wirken selbstbewusst.
Ich habe mir tatsächlich in meinem Leben noch nie eine Sonnenbrille gekauft und ich werde es auch, glaube ich, nicht tun, weil ich finde, eine Sonnenbrille ist ein komplett überflüssiges Accessoire.
Hä? Nein.
Doch, natürlich.
Meinst du, UV-Strahlen sind ein Ding, was Sonnenbrillenhersteller erfunden haben, ein Mythos?
Nein, nein, natürlich nicht. Aber du kannst auch einfach deine Augen zumachen. Der Körper hat eine eingebaute Sonnenbrille. Du kannst die Augen zumachen und dafür gibt es auch Hunde. Hunde führen dich. Ja, absolut. Sonnenhunde, die sogenannten Sonnenhunde. Vor allem letztens habe ich einen Hund gesehen, einen blinden Hund oder einen behinderten Hund oder sowas, und der hat einer Frau assistiert, die im Rollstuhl sass. Und da dachte ich mir, ist das eigentlich auch so ein Angebot von solchen Hundeverkäufern, die einen Hund anbieten, für Leute, die im Rollstuhl sitzen oder blind sind, der dich automatisch führt und zieht. Das ist wie so ein Streitwagen. Das wäre genial. Der Hund dich zieht automatisch schon in die Reihenfolge. Und da dachte ich mir, wäre es nicht eigentlich die beste Idee, statt blinden Hunden, blinden Pferde, auf die du dich einfach draufsetzt und die automatisch selbstständig dorthin galoppieren, wo du hin willst. Die musst du gar nicht führen. Aber sagen wir mal, wenn man in den DM will, als Blinder, haben wir mit dem Pferd dann ein Problem. PDM, Pferde DM. Finde ich gut, das wäre gut, das wäre das Richtige. Unten wäre was zu essen fürs Pferd. Ja, Pferd, du sagst auch Pferd.
Pferd ist dicker Pferd, sag ich. Nee, du sagst Pferd. Ich sag Pferd. Wie sagst du Pferd? Ich sag Pferd, ich versuche es zumindest. Du kommst aus München, ne? Ich komme aus München, ja. Dafür redest du aber schon. War das schon die erste Frage an mich? Ja, das war meine erste Frage. Ja, ich komme aus München. Ich habe eine Zeit lang in München gelebt, bin aber etwas außerhalb von München geboren worden. Und ich schiebe gleich die zweite Frage hinterher, weil mich die Antwort gar nicht interessiert hat. Bring it, bring it. Was ist denn dein grösster Traum? Mein grösster Traum ist es einmal, einen Oscar zu gewinnen. Was war das für ein Geräusch? Ach, die Leute sehen uns ja nicht. Das war Florentins Wills, äh, Florentin Wills Imitation einer Grille. Ha gut. Das war meine Imitation einer Grille. Das stimmt wirklich? Du willst einen Oscar gewinnen. Ja, wäre zumindest sehr cool. Also ich sage mal, so der Weg der Schauspielerei finde ich sehr interessant und sehr spannend und würde ich auch gerne weiter verfolgen. Und ich mag es auch einfach, objektive Beurteilungen zu bekommen, dass man was drauf hat. Schönster Mann der Welt wäre nichts für mich. Wirklich, wäre nichts für mich. Ist nicht objektiv. Ist auch ein Traum, den ich nicht wirklich aktiv verfolge, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ich auch nicht. Und deswegen, weil es einfach zu subjektiv ist, weißt du, du bist der schönste Mann der, du bist die schönste Frau der Welt, dann kommt der reichste Mann der Welt zu dir und sagt, Moment mal, wir haben hier ein paar Zahlen, die sagen ganz eiskalt, ich bin der reichste Mann der Welt, was hast du denn? Ja, nee, ich finde den schöner, ich finde meine Freundin schöner, bla bla bla. Weißt du, das ist sowieso, das ist halt auch ein Problem.
Findest du, dass Oscar wirklich so eine objektive Sache ist? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, es ist, Moment mal, Moment, objektiv gesehen ist es natürlich nicht objektiv, aber in der subjektiven Hinsicht kannst du zumindest sagen, hä, du hältst dich für einen guten Schauspieler, ich habe immerhin einen fucking Oscar gewonnen. Da kann man nicht mit argumentieren. Dass du natürlich nicht notwendigerweise der beste Schauspieler in dieser Kategorie warst zu dem Jahr, das ist ja klar. Aber du hast zumindest einen objektiven Anker, dass du sagen kannst, andere Leute, du hast ein Intersubjektiv, nennen wir es mal. Andere Leute haben gesagt, dass ich die beste Schauspielerin des Universums. Hat noch keinen Oscar bekommen, oder bin ich da falsch? Ich glaube, Moment, ich muss mir jetzt nachgucken. Kann man gut sein, dass die mal 2008... Ich überbrüche kurz, wir haben einen Kommentar bekommen. Nein, wir haben sicherlich keinen Kommentar bekommen. Falls ihr übrigens an unserer tollen Sendung teilnehmen wollt, könnt ihr das tun über Facebook, das Podcast UFO oder über Twitter, Hashtag UFO schreibt dort einfach... Ich habe nicht den Fehler bei Facebook, nur Podcast UFO einzugeben. Das hätte niemand gemerkt, Depp. Es gibt auch einen anderen Podcast, der heisst Podcast UFO aus Amerika. Ist es erst aufgefallen? Der hat 30.000 Likes. Ja, ist es erst aufgefallen, als wir schon mit drei Euro einen Beitrag von uns beworben. Wir haben ganz tolle Folgen und tolle Inhalte. Wir haben so viele, die gehen mir jetzt schon so auf den Sack, diese Penner. Und ich sag's euch, Freunde, wir, das ist auch mal so schlecht, Verbrüderung mit den Zuhörern, wir da draußen, wir da draußen, wir können es auch schaffen, einen noch erfolgreicheren Podcast zu starten als Podcast UFO. Vor allem, das ist auch so gut, dass wir uns als Lifestyle-Podcast messen wir uns mit einem Wissenschafts- und Verschwörungspodcast. Ich finde, aber wir sind auch sowas wie ein Verschwörungspodcast. Ja, auf eine gewisse Art schon. Aber um nochmal zurückzukommen auf meinen grössten Traum. Auf Nora Tschirner. Mein grösster Traum wäre es, einen erfolgreichen Podcast zu haben. Och Gott. Und ihr könnt mir diesen Traum ein Stück weit erfüllen. Aber nicht mit mir. Aber solange ich in diesem Raum mit dir sitze, wird es nicht passieren. In dem ihr diesen Podcast shared und liked und auf Twitter allen euren Freunden und Eltern schreibt, hört diesen Podcast. Apropos Eltern, wie muss man sich eigentlich Stefan Titze an Silvester vorstellen? Was machst du zu sehen? Was ist meine zweite Frage an Stefan Titze? Ich mag Silvester nicht. Ah, warum nicht? Das ist ein Datum, das er vorschreibt, gut drauf sein zu müssen, finde ich. Alle laufen mit Luftschlangen rum und Partyhüten und um zwölf müssen, wenn man eine Minute zu spät ist, dann fangen die Nachbarn nämlich schon an, das ist alles nur halb so lustig. Und man muss gut drauf sein, man muss um zwölf Uhr was trinken, anstoßen, das ist ein Datum, was zu jeder Uhrzeit was vorschreibt. Es läuft auf allen Sendern nur Dinner for One, danach läuft auf allen Sendern nur ein Herz und eine Seele, herausragender Sketch. Ich weiß nicht, Philipp, du gefällst mir gerade nicht. Wieso denn nicht? Nein, ich mag das nicht, du bist so ein Lavierer, du bist so ein, alle mögen X, also sage ich, dass X nicht gut ist. Du bist so ein richtiger Facebook-User, du bist so ein Typ, der schreibt, nein, nein, nein, wenn sich mal Campino einsetzt, für die armen, verhungernden Kinder in Afrika, dann bist du nicht so jemand, der dann ankommt und sagt, nein, die wollen sich doch nur profilieren, ne ne ne ne ne, du bist einfach immer dagegen.
Und das mögen Leute auch nicht. Und nein, das mögen nämlich Leute viel zu sehr, Leute, die dagegen sind, und das ist billig, das ist Anbiederung an die Zuschauerschaft, das finde ich zum Kotzen. Populismus hat nicht umsonst die Worte I-L-U drin, I lose you. Glaubst du also, dass die meisten Leute Silvester scheiße finden? Nein, ich glaube, Silvester ist objektiv etwas Gutes. Und du sagst, subjektiv ist es nicht gut. Nö, es ist nicht schlecht. Eigentlich ist es ziemlich geil. Ist das deine Meinung zu Silvester? Es ist nicht schlecht. Es ist eigentlich ziemlich geil, dass man Sachen auf die Straße werfen kann, die explodieren. Oder nicht explodieren. Einfach mal an Altmüll. Die meistens nicht abdecken. Einfach mal schön auf der Strasse entleeren.
Und ich meine, die zwölfjährigen Kinder von nebenan sprengen das schon in die Luft.
Also man kann eigentlich auf die Strasse hauen, was man will.
Und am nächsten Tag wird eh aufgeräumt.
Und es ist eigentlich auch gemeingefährlich, muss man sagen.
Aber das ist eigentlich gar keine so dumme Idee.
Man haut an Silvester einfach seinen ganzen Müll, sein Altglas auf die Strasse,
weil es wird sowieso alles sauber gemacht, wegen den Bördern.
Am nächsten Tag. Wer das bei euch sauber gemacht, bei mir, bei uns ist es nämlich Pflicht, da wo ich herkomme, ist nämlich die Pflicht, hier übrigens Frage 3, wo kommst du her? Ich komme aus Kamen, das Kamener Kreuz sagt vielen was. Nein, tut es nicht. Ausser Stauschau, weil er immer Stau ist, weil er die A1, die A2 trifft, ist eine Bildungslücke.
Die grössten beiden Autobahnen Deutschlands treffen sich, grössten weiß ich nicht, aber zumindest die 1 und die 2 halt. Die nummerll wichtigsten Autobahnen Deutschlands treffen sich an diesem Punkt. Und genau da ist nämlich Kahn... Nummerll? Das ist der Bruder von Karl Karl, von Rudi Karel. Oh Gott. Uff, uiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiui eher noch in Nora Tschinan-Oskar bekommen. Ich mag ja Silvester, ich finde das ja ganz toll, sie immer zu treffen mit alten Leuten, weil ich wohne ja mittlerweile ausserhalb meines alten Freundeskreises und dann mal wieder alle zu sehen und so toll und zu sagen hier und da. Feierst du zu Hause? Aber ich sag mal, früher war Silvester schon geil, weil ich war ein riesiger Böller-Fan. Ich auch, war ich auch. Und ich bin ja, ich habe das immer in der Nähe von Österreich gefeiert, ganz im südlichen Ende von Deutschland. Und dann sind wir nach Österreich gefahren und haben uns Ösi-Böller geholt, die sehr billig sind und sehr stark.
Und daraus haben wir dann immer Bomben gebaut.
Und was wir auch gemacht haben, wir haben so Gewehre gebaut. Wir haben uns so ein Stahlrohr genommen und das an einer Seite zugehämmert und dann da irgendwie ein Böller reingetan und eine Murmel und dann damit geschossen einfach. Das funktioniert sehr gut, tatsächlich. Das ist auch ein Trick zum Nachmachen, ne? Bitte nachmachen. Das ist ein Trick zum Nachmachen. Ne, ohne Witz, kein Witz. Und vor allem auch ohne Murmel hast du so einen gewissen Rückschlag, der einfach total cool ist als Kind, da so eine Art Muskete oder Gewehr zu haben.
Und das ist wirklich total geil.
Und da haben wir, das ist wirklich total cool.
Und was wirklich Spaß macht, ist, man kauft sich ganz viele Raketen und versucht an Silvester, wenn dann irgendwie die ganzen Eltern mit ihren Kindern auf den Hügel in der Nachbarschaft gehen und wir schauen uns das Silvester an, wir schauen uns das Feuerwerk an und bau uns noch hoch und du aus 30 Meter Entfernung in den Busch mit deinen Freunden auf diesen Hügel in die Menschenmenge der Feuerenden, die Silvesterraketen reinfeuernst und irgendwann die Eltern anfangen zu fliehen, weil was sollen sie denn machen? Aber die Kinder das cool finden und die Kinder so hüpfend und drehen sich in den Funken und inzwischen auch noch reinspringen und versuchen die Dinger zu fangen. Genau, aber es ist so eine gute Vorstellung. So, wir gehen jetzt da hin, ah, wir gehen doch direkt, pff, pff, pff, wir gehen wieder, na tschüss, bis morgen. Ich habe immer die Börder in der Mitte durchgebrochen. Ich finde das wirklich echt scheiße von dir, dass immer wenn ich anfange, etwas zu erzählen, direkt irgendein Mobile-Device aus, aber nur zu konten. Laptop-Device. Klar. Naja. Ich habe jedenfalls immer angefangen, die Börder in der Mitte durchzubrechen, das Schwarzpulver in grossen, ich habe so einen Teppich aus Taschentüchern gebastelt, habe da drin einen Riesenhaufen von diesem Zeug gehabt, habe es dann zugebunden. Da habe ich mir immer ganz viele Zündchen untereinander geknotet und dann habe ich es auf die Strasse gebracht, aber dann wurde es mir immer weggenommen. An diesem Punkt wurde mir das immer weggenommen. Moment mal! Natürlich! War das die antiklimatische Story, die ich in meinem Leben je gehört habe, auch inhaltlich. Aber für mich, das war auch das... Moment mal, wie es wurde dir weggenommen? Ich hatte immer eine antiklimatische Kindheit, hatte ich auch. Es wurde mir... Die Dinge wurden mir immer weggenommen. Ja, es war einfach gemeint gefährlich. Ich kann das... Moment, Moment! Ja, aber von wem denn? Wie alt warst du da? Noch relativ klein. Und von wem wurde es dir weggenommen? Ich hatte so eine Pyrophase. Ja, aber von wem wurde es dir weggenommen? Eltern. Ja, warum machst du das in der Nähe deiner Eltern? Weil ich war nicht so clever als Kind. Kinder sind ja nicht so clever. Die bauen sich halt diese Dinge. Naja, die wissen schon, was man darf und was man nicht darf. Das wissen sie. Ich habe meine Eltern dann gefragt, ja, kann ich vielleicht kurz mal in die Böller gehen, ich will sie mir angucken schon mal, damit ich ja mal vor Silvester weiss, wo die Zündschnur ist, sieht man ja im Winkel nicht mehr, so.
Für wie dumm hält man eigentlich als Kind seine Eltern? Seine Eltern, wahnsinnig dumm, man hält sich für wahnsinnig fies auch, weil die immer Dinge verbieten, was aber ganz gut ist, im Endeffekt hat sie es rausgestellt, ist immer ganz gut. Ich glaube auch, dass die Nachbarschaft es feiert, dass die Eltern mir das weggenommen haben. Es ist nämlich passiert, mein Vater hat nämlich damals wirklich mal sowas gebaut. Die haben sich aus Natriumkarbonat und so, das war nicht an Silvester, die waren wesentlich intelligenter als ich damals. Meine Eltern haben sich aus Natriumkarbonat, also mein Vater hat sich aus Natriumkarbonat mit seinen Brüdern eine Bombe gebastelt. Und die haben die, sagt er zumindest, erzählt er, wenn er was getrunken hat an Silvester, erzählt er dann immer, dass ... Du meinst Ahmed, dein Vater. Genau, genau. Ja, warum auch immer. Terroristengag, mein Gott, du steigst auf nichts ein. Ich steig darauf nicht ein, weil ich fühle das einfach drunter. Ja, okay, sorry. Drüber. Drüber, runter. Jedenfalls hat er das angezündet und ist angeblich die halbe Nachbarschaft in Luft geflogen. Es sind angeblich aus Telefonzellen Scheiben rausgeflogen, das Rosenbeet des Nachbarn war weg. Das sind so die Dinge, die man damals gehört hat. Und dann nimmt man natürlich seinem Kind das Ding weg, was er da baut. Das ist aber nicht sehr clever als Vater, seinem Kind das zu erklären, weil das Kind sagt, ja, das mache ich aber sicher auch. Kleiner Tipp an euch zuhause, falls ihr vielleicht nicht so gut an Böller rankommt, Wunderkerzen, nehmt Wunderkerzen und zerbröselt diese Masse, die um den Draht herum ist, und die könnt ihr zum Beispiel in einen Tischtennisball, macht da ein Loch rein, füllt da dieses ganze Staub rein, zündet oben an, wunderschön. Ich fand Wunderkerzen immer wahnsinnig langweilig. Wunderkerzen sind auch langweilig, weil man nicht weiß, wie man damit umgehen soll. Was ist auch sehr geil, was ich früher als Kind sehr geliebt habe, waren so Mini-Raketen aus Österreich, die nicht explodiert sind. Es waren nur Raketen... Oder wenn dann in eine Richtung geflogen sind, wo sich die Wetter besser nicht explodiert werden. Nein, aber die... Das ist ja wirklich immer mein allerschönster Anblick an Silvester. Man ist Silvester, man stösst an mit seinen Freunden und man sieht drüben die Nachbarseltern, Herr und Frau Schneider, ein wenig in die Jahre gekommen. Mit 70 sagen sie, wir haben eine Rakete gekauft bei edeka gehen noch mal raus wir können nicht mehr so gut stehen wenn wir nicht mehr so gut das gleichgewicht halten weil das ist ein bisschen zu wir haben auch schon ein paar lütten intus aber jetzt doch was soll's denn marianne jetzt zünden wir doch die rakete einfach an dann gehen die stapfen die in den garten in den schnee stecken die rakete den Schnee. Hast du das Feuerzeug dabei, Marianne? Nein, Bernd, ich hol's doch. Ich geh doch mal rein, haben wir beim Racklet vergessen. Warte noch mal auf mich und dann gehen sie rein und dann zünden die diese Rakete an und natürlich hebt sie nicht ab. Oder sie fällt um. Genau, es gibt nämlich die zwei Paare. Je nachdem, wie viel Lütten sie schon getrunken haben, fällt sie entweder um und geht erst gar nicht an, oder sie fällt um, an und rast in die nächste Menschengruppe. In die Wohnung. Ja, rast in die Wohnung. Rast in die Wohnung und das war's dann. Die Briefmarkensammlung dahin, das teure Porzellan von der Uroma dahin. Genau, die Telefonbücher, wo die Kinder drinstehen, kaputt. Oder natürlich die andere Variante, die Rakete steckt zu tief im Schnee und sie hebt nicht ab. Und da gucken Marianne und Imgad noch zwei Sekunden zu und sich, oh, okay. Es ist schon zu spät, auch um wegzulaufen noch. Aber sie treten trotzdem diese tapfere kleine Flucht an, sie drehen sich um in dem Schnee und tapfen voran, aber keine Chance. Boom! Sie stehen mitten in den Funken, zusammengezuckt. Und der Kaschmirmantel fängt dahin. Fängt so ganz eklig an zu stinken. Dahin, dahin, die Wollmütze vom Schwiegersohn, dahin, der gute Schal, aus dem Krieg, weg, alles dahin, aber das ist immer schön und dann so, ja, das, nächstes Jahr lassen wir das besser, kommt dann, ja, aber man merkt es und nächsten Tag fragt man sich, weil man da doch nicht mehr weiß, was man alles getrunken hat und was alles passiert ist, fangen sich, wo ist denne zu suchen. Und die Kinder denken, oh nein, jetzt werden unsere Eltern dement. Dabei können sie sich einfach nicht mehr daran erinnern, dass sie sich wirklich verbrannt haben. Aber ist das alles so kaputt gegangen im grossen Feuerwerksmassaker? Genau. Was ist hier drin passiert? Oh, die Oma hat kein Gleichgewicht mehr, sie läuft gegen die Schränke. Nein, es war die Rakete von letztem. Genau, sie hat die Muttermaler im, das ist alles die Dinge. Das sieht aber nicht gesund aus, ist ein bisschen zu schwarz und die Ränder sind nicht gleichmäßig. Musst du dann nicht mal zum Arzt, genau so, und dann musst du auch mal wieder zum Arzt, da geht alles wieder von vorne los. Alte Menschen sind unterschätzt. Schrecklich, ja, schwer unterschätzt. Und deswegen kommen wir jetzt mal. Wir haben den ersten Gast, der traut sich nicht ganz ins Studio rein, tatsächlich. Gott sei Dank. Der einzige Gast, den wir hatten, unser Tontechniker, ist mittlerweile auch schon gegangen. Ich weiss nicht, ob das ein gutes Zeichen ist für unseren Podcast-Oil nicht. Die vierte Frage an Stefan Titze. Stefan, hast du denn schon Geschenke für Weihnachten? Ich habe mir schon überlegt. Ja, was denn? Und da bin ich den Stephans von vor ein und zwei Jahren deutlich voraus. Ich habe mir schon überlegt, was ich schenke. Du bist so ein Last-Minute-Käufer, oder? Auf jeden Fall. Amazon-Love-Minute-Käufer. Das ist wesentlich ganz so schlimm. Aber man kann relativ gut schätzen, wann das Pakete ankkommen. Ganz kurz, wie sieht es denn bei dir die Aufstellung aus? Wie viele Geschenke brauchst du, für wen? Sehr wenig, Eltern eigentlich nur. Nur Eltern, du hast keine Geschwister? Ne, keine Geschwister, Einzelkind, verwöhntes Einzelkind. Boah, ich komme so scheiße weg. Du kommst so unfassbar unsympathisch. Einzelkinder sind wahnsinnig unsympathisch, immer. Gerade ich. Dann versuche ich, es ist wirklich wahnsinnig unsympathisch. Wir haben eben ein paar Gründe aufgezählt, warum ich unsympathisch bin. Du siehst gut aus und du bist hauptberuflich lustig. Wenn dich jemand fragt, was machst du, ich schreibe Gags für eine Fernsehsendung, dann sag ich, ja, okay, zeig mir mal, wie lustig du bist, du Spacko. Gut, dass du jetzt erwähnst, dass man Witze schreibt, jetzt werden die Lüder nämlich sagen, was? Sowas schreibt. Aber genau das ist die Redaktion. Man singt automatisch im Humorverständnis und man sagt, man beschäftigt sich beruflich mit Comedy, ist man sofort der Unlustige, weil man kann diese Erwartungen nur enttäuschen. Weil es ist was ganz anderes, ob du privat oder sozial lustig bist oder ob du die Fähigkeit hast, Gags zu schreiben, die man in den Fernsehsendungen verwenden kann. Aber trotzdem denken Leute, weil zum Beispiel, das ist auch so ein Ding, Comedy ist das Subjektivste, was es gibt. Und zwar denkt ja jeder, zu beurteilen, beurteilen zu können, was lustig ist und was nicht. Und ob man selber lustig ist, kann man meistens sehr gut sagen. Ja, weiss nicht, ich habe in dem Satz noch die Richtung geändert, weil das andere wäre zu erwarten. Und zum Falschen, im Satz die falsche Abbildung genommen. Das ist nämlich genau im Flugzeug, wenn die fragen, ja, mit so Schinken oder das Käsebaguette, ich sage immer das Falsche, weil mir im Satz auffällt, nein, das wolltest du nicht.
Ich hätte gerne das Schinken, man denkt das Schinken, fuck, und wenn du das nochmal änderst, dann regn die Reihen vor dir wieder auf und das ist einfach scheiße.
Ja, das kannst du nicht machen, das kannst du nicht bringen.
Weil du schon am Notausdruck bist.
Nein, aber also angenommen, also bleib mal im Kunstgewerbe, aber wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel sagst, ich bin Schriftsteller, ich schreibe Romane, dann würden viele Leute vielleicht ein Buch lesen und sagen, ich interessiere mich nicht so für Bücher und so, keine Ahnung, kann ich nicht so anfangen, aber sie würden nicht sofort sagen, es ist schlecht. Bei Humor hingegen hat jeder das maximale Verständnis in seinen Augen und kann maximal kompetent bewerten, ob was gut ist oder nicht. Ja, weil es ein reiner Meinungsstreit ist. Ja, es gibt ja schon sowas wie Humor, irgendwie Technik, Hum, Handwerk und so. Das ist ja der Handwerkshumor von Donen Vorhause. Die Reaktion ist immer emotional, ist immer das Lachen und dann kann man immer sagen, finde ich nicht lustig, dafür nicht. Und das ist tatsächlich sehr unangenehm, weil man tatsächlich sich damit beschäftigen muss, ich beschäftige mich vielleicht mein ganzes Leben mit einer Kunst, die von vielen Menschen vielleicht einfach nicht anerkannt wird. Wenn du sagst, ich bin Stabhochspringer, dann kann dir niemand diese Zahl nehmen, ich kann zwei Meter achtzig hochspringen als Stabhochspringer, das kann ich, dann sagen die Leute, okay, cool, aber lustig, könntest du tatsächlich nach fünfzig Jahren Karriere deine Ausbeute bei null liegen, in den Augen von manchen oder von vielen. Das ist aber Kunst, du beschreibst gerade den Kunstbegriff und den Steilung und den Kunstbegriff allgemein. Ja, aber ich glaube, bei Kunst generell können sich die Leute nicht so eine Meinung bilden. Du kannst ein Bild malen, klar, bei Witzen auch. Du kannst ein Bild malen und es kann entweder gut gefunden werden, es kann nur witzig, auch Bilder können witzig gefunden werden. Ja, aber nicht jeder sagt von sich selbst, er hat die maximale Kompetenz, Bilder zu beurteilen. Wenn du ihm sagst, ich habe ein Bild gemalt von irgendwie einem abstrakten Fisch, dann sagt er, ja gut, ich interessiere mich nicht so viel Kunst, sieht schon ganz okay aus, keine Ahnung. Wohingegen bei Humor gibt es keine, es gibt keine Elite bei Humor. Ich hätte noch keinen gehört, der sagt, wow, dieser blaue Kreis auf dem Bild, und das Bild ist nur ein blauer Kreis, finde ich das beste Bild, was ich je gesehen habe. Diese Leute hörst du nämlich nicht. Ja, aber jetzt bitte fang nicht mit einem moderne Kunstrand an, das ist wirklich das Lächelnste. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, mit einem, das kennt dich aber auch mein schwarzer Strich. Genau, das sagen nämlich alle. Nein, halt die Fresse, da will ich gar nicht drüber reden, das ist mir zu dumm. Ne, das sagen… boah, ich glaube jetzt hast du mindestens zehn Zuschauer verloren. Ja, das ist okay, geht, euch will ich nicht, euch Zuschauer will ich nicht. Haut ab! Nein, man muss ja sagen, ich finde es ja gut, die Idee muss man ja gehabt haben, finde ich, aber die meisten Leute werden sagen, das ist scheiße, das ist doch keine Kunst. Aber schau mal. Ich glaube, beigemein sich die Leute... Ich glaube, nein. Ich hau mal auf den Tisch jetzt. Ich glaube, dass...
Der schlechteste Tisch, um auf den Tisch zu hauen. Der hat so ein kleiner, er bricht wahrscheinlich dabei zusammen jetzt, aber ist mir egal.
Nein.
Man muss dazu sagen, Kunst allgemein ist etwas, worüber Leute meinen, urteilen zu können.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, dass bei Kunst bei den meisten Bereichen die Leute zu einem gewissen Grad akzeptieren, dass es eine gewisse Form von Verständnis und Erfahrung braucht, um ein Kunstwerk adäquat bewerten zu können. Wenn dir jemand ein abstraktes Kunstwerk vorsetzt oder eine Skulptur, kannst du natürlich schon subjektiv sagen, es gefällt mir spontan oder es gefällt mir nicht. Aber auf der anderen Seite kannst du sagen, würde ich mich vielleicht mehr mit Kunst beschäftigen, hätte ich ein größeres Verständnis darüber, könnte ich es besser bewerten. Von daher sage ich vielleicht eher, wenn du zum Beispiel, du gehst in eine Oper und sagst, ja, damit kann ich halt nichts anfangen, würde ich zum Beispiel auch sagen. Aber ich würde nicht sagen, es ist schlecht. Zauberflöte, wahnsinnig gut. Okay, das waren alle, die ich kenne, weiter. Ist auch keine Oper, ist eine Operette. Ist vielleicht sogar falsch, man weiss es nicht, Ding Dong. Aber das ist bei Humor genau nicht der Fall. Bei Humor gibt es nicht diese elitäre Handwerksverständnisse. Ich erkläre es ja nicht nur die Hügelklässerung zum Zuschauen. So, und deswegen, das ist ein Problem, weil zum Beispiel, was meinst du, wie viel Prozent der Leute würden auf die Frage, hast du Humor oder nicht, mit Ja antworten? Schätzung. Du fragst alle Deutschen, fragst alle Deutschen in der Welt, alle Deutschen, die es auf der Welt gibt, und fragst sie, haben sie Humor oder nicht? Ich glaube, die meisten würden ja sein. Ja, natürlich, aber wie viel Prozent? Hundert Prozent sagen ja. Hundert Prozent? Ja, 99, es gibt nicht 100 Prozent, 99,3 Prozent, man wird auch manche nicht finden, weil die in Thailand irgendwie im Dschungel leben oder so. Ja, Bunga-Bunga-Fallen. 80 Prozent, das sind doch alle Leute, die man findet, diese 80 Prozent, quasi diese
100 Prozent. Du siehst das zu technisch. Wir müssen noch die Kinder ausschliessen,
die verstehen die Frage nicht. 100 Prozent, die das
anklicken, weil oh, toll.
100 Prozent der Leute, die das anklicken,
die, jetzt bin ich komplett,
die Leute, die diese Frage beantworten, werden sagen, sie haben Humor.
Ja, ganz genau. Aber ich glaube,
das ist, glaube ich, das Maximum. Wenn du
sagst, haben sie Musikgeschmack, das ist auch so eine Frage, gibt es Leute, die von sich selbst sagen, sie haben keinen guten Musikgeschmack? Das ist ja Quatsch. Das ist ja kein guter Musikgeschmack. Jeder von sich hat ja den Musikgeschmack, der für ihn am besten ist. Du hörst ja die Musik, die dir am besten gefällt. Aber geht's dir nicht manchmal auch so? Das ist ein bisschen blöd. Nein, aber geht's dir nicht manchmal auch so, dass du... Es sagt keiner, oh, man ist vor dir bei Playlist gefecht mit mir. Moment mal, nein, na ja, manchmal höre ich auch Musik, die mir nicht gefällt. Ich habe alle Liga gepackt mit meinen Playlist gefecht, die mir nicht gefallen. Ich habe tatsächlich, bei mir habe ich relativ auf die Phase, dass ich so nebenbei arbeite und Musik höre und dann kommt zu dieser Moment der Realisation, Alter, was höre ich echt für eine beschissene Musik eigentlich. Frage zwei, was hörst du für eine Musik, was hat du für eine Musik, was hat du für eine Musik? Ich würde das noch ganz gerne zu Ende bringen. Und zwar geht es mir manchmal so, dass ich sage, ich höre Musik bei mir, meine eigene Musik, sozusagen die ich selber ausgewählt habe, und dann höre ich Musik von einem Freund und sage, hm, dessen Musik ist besser als meine. Der hat auch in meinen Prinzipien gemessen einen besseren Musikgeschmack als ich. Und dann sage ich, gib mir alle deine Alben, zeig mir alles, was du hast, höre mir das andere, ist tatsächlich besser, ist ein Upgrade und ich höre nur noch seine Musik. Da kann man objektiv sagen, Das ist ein Wechsel der Geschmacksrichtung. Nein, ich glaube nicht, das ist ein Wechsel. Du hast Sachen halt noch nicht entdeckt. Natürlich verändert sich der Geschmack auch, aber es geht natürlich auch darum, dass du die Sachen noch nicht entdeckt hast. Der Musikgeschmack richtet sich ja danach, was einem gefällt und nicht, was man alles kennt. Ja, aber du kannst nur das gut finden, was du kennst. Genau, je mehr du kennst, umso mehr Sachen kannst du gut finden, ja, aber du findest es ja besser als das, was du vorhin. Und umso bessere Sachen findest du für dich auch. Ich finde, wir drehen uns ein bisschen im Kreis. Ich fand, das war nur ein Beispiel dafür, dass ich zumindest denke, dass man auch besseren Musikgeschmack haben kann als andere. Und ich von mir zum Beispiel würde sagen, ich habe keinen guten Musikgeschmack. Einfach mal, um jetzt der Anadog zu sein, der sagt, ui, toll, er hat so viel Selbstreflexion und Selbstwertungsgabe. Oh, er will mal wieder gegen den Strom schwimmen. Er ist wahrscheinlich der einzige Mensch, der jemals sagt, er hat keinen Musikgeschmack. Okay, gut, aber nein, Thema abgeschlossen. Um auf die Frage noch zu antworten. Das ist echt anstrengend, so viel zu reden. Um auf die Frage noch zu antworten, kurz. Ich will meinem Vater einen Wurststrauß schenken und meiner Mutter will ich ein Massagekissen schenken. Aha, ein Massagekissen. Hoffentlich hören die die Sender nicht vorbeigehen. Was genau ist ein Massagekissen? Ähm, ach, weiss ich nicht. Irgendwas. Ich finde, das sind einfach... Der Bestseller bei Amazon, der kann ja nicht schlecht sein. Komplette Crap-Sachen. Massagesessel. Ich wohne in Berlin zwei Häuser weiter von einem Laden, der nur Massagesessel verkauft. Jedes Mal gehe ich daran vorbei und denke mir, was für eine Geldverschwendung. Wer kauft diesen Scheiss? Kein Mensch. Das ist ein fucking Sessel, der halt so ein bisschen vibriert und rubbelt, aber du denkst dir, das bringt eigentlich nicht wirklich was, das ist nur nervig. Das Ding wiegt einfach acht Tonnen. Ich glaube, die schwersten Gegenstände der Welt sind Massagesessel. Und es brauchen alte Leute. Da musst du den Sessel, da brauchst du diesen scheiss schweren Sessel, Massagesessel, musst du dann auf den Treppenlift tiefen und dann kannst du eigentlich für alte Leute es nicht mehr. Nein, aber alte Leute würden sich sowas nicht mehr ins Haus holen, die sagen, sowas brauche ich nicht, viel zu technisch, ich brauche eher ein Playstation, ich brauche eine Playstation, Counter-Strike, ich glaube, dass auch alte Leute, was ist die Zielgruppe von Massagesessen, das ist eine gute Frage eigentlich, können wir mal anrufen? Ich finde, wir rufen mal an, rufen mal an Massage, lass mal was machen, was die Leute jetzt denken, Also ich glaube erstmal, dass nicht mehr so viele hören jetzt uns gerade. Lehnen wir eigentlich auf schon? Nein. Ich glaube, dass wir erstmal was machen sollten, was die Leute noch immer ins Boot holt. Die jetzt vorskippen und die Leute, die bis jetzt hier vorgespielt haben und gesagt haben, oh, da passiert was, sie rufen wohl wen an. Das ist was Spannendes, das ist was, wo die Leute jetzt aufmerksam werden, wo sie anhalten, Soundcloud, Podcast, de, worüber wir laufen.
iTunes. iTunes? Ich habe jetzt mal
Massagesessel-Kontakt.
Ziehen wir nicht die iTunes-Podcast-Branche
total in den Dreck, wenn wir da laufen,
wenn wir da in einer Reihe stehen mit anderen Podcasts,
die das wirklich ernst meinen?
Ich rufe die Massagesessel-Hotline an.
Es gibt tatsächlich eine Massagesessel-Hotline.
Aber mach bitte auf laut.
Hallo.
Okay, wir hören mal rein. Man muss auch dazu sagen, dass es halb acht ist, also wirklich nicht die Zeit für Hotlines oder dafür das überhaupt… Hallo, ein wunderschönen guten Abend, Martin Weber hier mein Name. Ich hätte eine Frage zu Massagesesseln, bin ich da richtig bei Ihnen? Da muss ich mal schauen, also bei mir jetzt... Ist das nicht die Massagesessel-Hotline? Hallo? Ja, ich schaue hier gerade nach, kleinen Moment. Kein Problem. Ich kann gerne Ihre Anfrage aufnehmen. Ja, es wäre erstmal nur eine Frage. Ich bin ja erstmal froh, dass wir sie erreicht haben. So spät erreicht man eigentlich kaum noch jemanden.
Wir haben schon bei Obi angerufen und so. Mein Kollege Gustav Schleicher ist auch hier.
Hallo.
Und zwar haben wir die Frage, und zwar, was sind denn so die generellen Zielgruppen von Massagesesseln? Welche Altersgruppen kaufen denn am ehesten Massagesessel?
Haben wir uns gefragt. Also wie gesagt, Sie sind jetzt bei mir nicht in der Hotline gelandet.
Was glauben Sie denn?
Ich kann es gerne weiterleiten an unserem Kundenservice und ja, dann einen Rückruftermin vereinbaren.
Ja, das wäre sehr gut. Können Sie uns weiter verbinden?
Am besten jetzt zurückrufen.
Leider nein.
Haben Sie da vielleicht eine persönliche Meinung dazu? Was glauben Sie denn? Also, wie gesagt, ich vermerke gerne einen Rückruf und ja, man will... Na gut, Sie müssen jetzt nicht so eine Schärfe reinbringen, ich habe ja nur gefragt... Naja, ich meine nur, weil ich überlege gerade zum Thema Weihnachtsgeschenke, ob das in Ordnung ist, Masage... Sie sind jetzt aber bei mir lediglich in der Anrufannahme gelandet, ja?
Ach so.
Also gut, aber mein Anruf haben Sie jetzt angenommen. Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Wie bitte?
Unter welcher Nummer... Sie müssen mich auch mal ausreden lassen.
Oh, entschuldige.
Unter welcher Nummer wären Sie dann zu erreichen, Herr Weber?
Das ist die 017...
Aber meinst du, meine Mutter ist 52 Jahre alt. Meinen Sie, das ist ein gutes Geschenk, ein Massagesessel? Oder ist das zu alt, ist das zu technisch? Das weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie Ihre Mutter technisch bewandert ist. Ja, nicht so. Deswegen ist das, man wehr ja dann, dass es auch benutzt wird. Wenn das ja nicht angenommen wird, ist das ja immer irgendwie blöd. Ja, ich kann Ihnen aber dazu jetzt, wie gesagt, keine Aussage machen. Würden Sie sich denn über den Massagesessel freuen? Wie alt sind Sie denn? Ich persönlich schon, ja. Ja, wirklich? Herr Rieber, wir können das doch jetzt hier nicht diskutieren. Also ich habe Ihre Anfrage jetzt aufgenommen, ich leite das an unseren Kundenservice weiter und Sie kann natürlich auch zeitgleich immer mal eine E-Mail schreiben. So Soll ich Ihnen meine E-Mail-Adresse ansagen? Wie alt sind Sie denn? Also nur als Vergleich zu meiner Mutter. Herr Weber, ich werde mit Ihnen jetzt nicht weiter darüber reden. Okay, Entschuldigung. So, möchten Sie eine E-Mail-Adresse? Das wäre sehr freundlich, ja. Ja, das wäre... Und da erreiche ich Sie direkt persönlich? Da erreichen Sie mich nicht persönlich, da erreichen Sie auch einen Kundenservice. Okay, aber jetzt so vom Altersrahmen, so 20 bis 30, 30 bis 40, nur so das Jahrzehnt. Ich kann Ihnen nicht sagen, welche Leute diese E-Mail erreichen wird, Herr Weber. Nein, aber Sie. Ich weiss überhaupt gar nicht, was ich antworten soll auf Ihre Fragen.
Sie fragen mich, wie alt ich bin, Sie fragen, ob ich einen Massagesessel haben möchte.
Ich verstehe, das ist ein ganz absurdes Gespräch, was wir hier gerade führen.
Nein, aber nur als Vergleich.
Und ich leite jetzt Ihre Anfrage, ob der Zielgruppe dieser Massagesessel, gerne weiter und lege jetzt auf.
Ja, ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend, Herr Weber. Ebenfalls.he Weihnachten, danke. Es ist immer halb, na gut, das möchte ich, wir haben einen grossen Teil wahrscheinlich rausgepiept von den Sachen, weil wir natürlich auch keine Erlaubnis haben, das auszustrahlen, aber uiuiuiuiuiui. Aber ist das echt... Also Wissenschaft will ich nicht haben. Du hast die Massagesessel-Hotline angerufen und du bist gelandet bei einer Frau, die uns keine, aber auch gar keine Ausgut geben wollte über Massagesessel, die ihr Massagesessel nichtmals gut findet, glaube ich. Weil sie die Anrufannahme, das ist ja mal die gröbste Bezeichnung für irgendwas überhaupt. Die Frau, von der unsere Eltern erzählen, unsere Großeltern erzählen, die damals mal die Anrufe weitergeleitet hat, so eine ist es, glaube ich, die alle Anrufe der Welt annimmt, die nicht zu bestimmten Zielen führen. Ich fand es auch gut, dass du auch versucht hast, dich ins Gespräch einzuhalten, aber das Handy ist zwei Meter von dir entfernt. Was sie gehört hat, ist irgendein Trottel im Hintergrund, der irgendwelche Fragen stellt. Frag sie doch mal. Ich glaube, sie wollte auch gar nicht noch einiges Gespräch haben. Ich glaube, sie war mit dir schon überfordert. Ich glaube nicht, nein. Die war sauer. Die war richtig sauer. Massagesessen, jetzt verbinde ich mit Massagesessen immer sehr, dass es 52 Jahre alte alte Frauen. Aber warum, also habe ich irgendwas Falsches gesagt?
Man fragt Frauen nicht nach dem Alter.
Ja, sie kann ja grob sagen, sie hat ja mein Dilemma verstanden.
Sie kann ja sagen, ja, ich bin 40, mir gefällt's, aber ob das einer 50-Jährigen gefällt, weiss ich nicht.
Das war so eine Frau, die bei Radio-Scherzanrufen, glaube ich, gerne genommen würde.
Ja, also, enjoy, meldet euch, ich leite die Nummer weiter an euch, das ist glaube ich eine Goldgrube. Einfach damit du noch mal nicht über... Das piep ich alles raus, das funktioniert nicht. Aber damit du ein bisschen Arbeit beim Piepen hast, sag ich noch mal ein paar Mal... Auch im Laufe des Gesprächs werde ich noch ein paar Mal... Meine Herr, ich habe echt ein schlechtes Gewissen jetzt ein bisschen, oder? Wollen wir noch mal anrufen und zu entschuldigen? Nein, nein, nein, das ist echt... Wir landen mit sich halt woanders. Das ist zu assi, wenn dann rufst du noch mal an. Aber ich will gerne wissen, ob alle Kollegen bei ihr so sind. Nein, das ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, die Einzige, das ist halb acht, da ruft kein Mensch mehr an. Ich habe ja auch mal in einem Callcenter gearbeitet und ich weiß, wie das ist. Du hast aber auch schon angerufen. Nein, ich habe nicht angerufen, ich wurde nur angerufen, das möchte ich hier sagen. Ich habe zwar in einem Callcenter gearbeitet, was natürlich Abschaum ist, klar, aber ich wurde nur angerufen als technischer Support. Ich habe niemanden belästigt. Konntest du den meisten Leuten helfen? Ich konnte den meisten Leuten helfen, denn die Probleme, die sie hatten, waren sehr... Hatten die meisten Leute ernsthafte Probleme? Nein. Hättest du denen helfen können, wenn die meisten Leute ernsthafte Probleme gehabt hätten? Ja. Echt? Ich hätte ihnen bei allen ihren Problemen helfen können. Ich war sehr hilfsbereit, immer. Aber was hat dich denn da so befähigt? Was haben die für Fragen gestellt? Also zum Beispiel haben wir für einen Telefonservice gearbeitet, wo man eine gewisse Eingabe tätigen musste ins Telefon. Da hieß es dann, bitte geben Sie jetzt Ihre Nummer ein. Und dann musste man die Nummer, die man hatte, eintippen. So. 99 Prozent der Menschen haben die Nummer gesagt. Fünf, eins, zwei, drei. Und dann, bitte wiederholen Sie Ihre Eingabe. Wir haben Ihre Eingabe nicht verstanden. Dann haben Sie noch mal gesagt, dann irgendwann haben Sie beiufen und gesagt, ja, Abzocke, Geld, was soll das, ich habe dafür gezahlt und was fällt Ihnen eigentlich ein? Sofort wütend. Mutbürger. Also wirklich von der ersten Sekunde extrem. Ist der Deutsche ein Mutbürger? Ja, total. Total. Und du so, ja, haben Sie die Nummer denn gesagt? Ja, die müssen Sie eintippen. Ja, das steht ja nirgendwo und was soll das denn? Also wirklich sofort. Was fällt Ihnen ein? Was fällt Ihnen ein? Also total strange und vor allem das sind so Leute, mit denen hat man privat nichts zu tun. Man muss ja immer mal wieder sagen, man lebt in einer sozialen Blase von Menschen, die man gut findet und die relativ ähnlich zu einem sind. Aber es gibt da draußen, die meisten Menschen sind komplett ganz anders als man selbst. Hundert Prozent ganz anders, ein ganz anderer Menschentyp. Das war die Frau eben, die Frau, bei der wir eben gelandet sind.
Ja, glaube ich, da würde ich privat,
die schaut die Sendungen nicht, die wir gut finden,
die schaut die Sendungen nicht, die wir machen zum Teil.
Was schaut seine Frau?
Die hört das Podcast und von nicht. Gute Frage.
Aber die kann ich ihr nicht stellen, weil sie sonst ausrastet.
Ich würde sie doch mal fragen.
Dilemma.
Nein, nein, nein, das ist dann schon Belästigung.
Da finde ich, geht es zu weit.
Dann lass uns voran das anrufen.
Ich finde, wir sind ein moralischer Podcast, wir haben eine ethische Überpflichtung,
auch unseren Zuhörern gegenüber, aber auch anderen Menschen. Aber nee, ich möchte auch da mal unseren Zuschauern nochmal unter die Arme greifen und sagen, denkt immer daran... Der Topflurz wegzunehmen ist nicht gut. Denkt immer daran, dass die meisten Menschen nicht so sind wie ihr selbst. Es ist tatsächlich so. Man glaubt es kaum, man denkt ja immer, alle sind so wie man selbst. Eigentlich denkt man schon, dass man der Beste ist, oder? Also das ist ja so eine menschliche Sache, dass man generell denkt, man ist der Beste. Okay, ich hab verschissen bei allen. Aber jetzt so langsam, jetzt so langsam wie erst du dich wieder von oben kommst, Schritt für Schritt, ja, ja, ja, Schritt für Schritt. Nein, man denkt ja generell schon der Beste und man denkt eigentlich auch immer, alle sollten so machen wie man selbst, oder? Man wird aber auch oft bestätigt darin, dass man der Beste ist. Ja, weil man natürlich sich nur die Bestätigung erinnert, man an diese Bestätigung. Kinder habe ich noch nicht gelesen, also Babys, Kleinkinder, die vergessen oft schlechte Erinnerungen, vergessen die einfach, die können da nichts für, aber die verdrängen von Natur aus. Ja, aber das ist ja sehr gut. Ja, natürlich ist das sehr gut. Aber es sind nicht kritikfähig. Natürlich ist es sehr gut. Babys sind nicht kritikfähig. Babys sind dämlich, Babys checken nicht, wenn man den Ball wegnimmt, dann denken die, der ist weg, der existiert nicht mehr, das Universum hat kein Plasma für den Ball. Hat es, Kinder, liegt da falsch. Es sind genug Bälle, es gibt genug Bälle auf der Welt. Es ist einfach nur dämlich, guck mal hinter den Rücken nach, dass Kinder darauf nicht kommen. Ich bin nämlich mal in einem Deutschlandtrikot, da war noch WM und ich laufe dann mit Deutschlandschal und Bier und bauchfrei und Sandalen und Deutschlandtrikot laufe ich dann rum. Und dann ist eine Mutter gekommen mit einem Kleinkind und hat gesagt, guck mal da drüben, der Junge, der hat ein Deutschlandtrikot an. Dann denke ich mir, warum das muss ich dem Kind sagen? Kinder sind dämlich anscheinend. Das Kind hat, sieht man doch, dass ich ein Deutschlandtrikot an habe, das muss man dem noch nicht sagen. Ja, man hat ja so einen Drang, die Welt zu erklären. Wenn ich ein Kind hätte, ich würde ihm alles erklären. Wenn ich Mutbitter sehe, die sagen, hier, nimm Baller, hier, Baller, nein, das heißt Ball, under macht es auch noch nicht mal kürzer. Hier ein Wauwau, ein Wauwau. Wauwau, es heißt Hund, Wauwau hat zwei Silben, das macht es auch nicht mal kürzer, das macht es auch nicht mal schöner. Wauwau ist ein helliges Kackwort. Drei. Hund. Stefan hat mir letztens erklärt, wie man rausfällt, ob man da Silben haben, und zwar hat er getrenntnt T-Ger. Und das war seine Hilfe, zu klatschen.
T-S-M-A-T-R-O-S-E. So muss man das machen. So trennt man Silben. Er ist verkackt, das heißt natürlich T-Ger. Oder Pfft-Z-Ger, Pfft-Z-Ger. Ich bin ein Tiger, du bist ein Hund, wir leben alle in einem Abgrund, Schlund, Hund, Grund, Abgrund, Fund.
Es gibt nicht einfach nur Worte aneinander reihen, die ähnlich klingen.
So funktioniert nicht. Es ist nicht dann auch eine Klasse höher sogar, weil man versucht einfach nur ganz viel...
Man verzichtet komplett auf Sätze und konzentriert sich nur auf Worte.
Genau.
Oh, ich werde angerufen.
Oh, ist es der Rückruf?
Ist es der Rückruf? Oh, wenn es jetzt schon kommt. Hallo, guten Tag. Hallo? Hallo? Hallo? Ah, Sie haben angerufen. Richtig, Martin Weber hier mein Name. Ich habe eine Frage zu Massagesesseln. Ja. Und zwar würde mich interessieren, welche Altersgruppen sich denn vorrangig für Massagesessel interessieren, also was ist da so nicht mal um die 20 oder 25, also wir haben schon... Moment, was, polierte Leute? Entschuldigung, das habe ich nicht verstanden. Besser situierte Leute.
Ah, situiert, okay. Also älter.
Alte.
Besser verdienende, die geburtenstarken Jahrgänge beispielsweise im Moment ganz starke.
Reden wir beide von Massagesesseln? Welche Jahrgänge waren das?
In Deutschland die geburtenstarken Jahrgänge werden Sie doch kennen, die Baby-Boomer-Jahre kennen wir nicht? Ja, doch natürlich. Wir haben Anfang der 70er die Vampires gross gemacht, und Mitte der 70er wurde Spielköch gebraucht, Playmobil, Lego, und heute tun hier Leute was für ihre Gesundheit. Verstehe. Meine Sorge ist so ein bisschen, dass meine Mutter das nicht ganz annehmen wird. Die sagt dann, das höre ich häufiger, so, das ist zu technisch, das brauche ich nicht, das wiegt acht Tonnen, wie soll ich das mit dem Lifter, Treppenlift, die Treppe hochkriegen. Und das wird man natürlich nicht lieb, wenn das dann auch nicht angenommen wird, das Geschenk. Ja, dann müssen Sie da mit ihr vorher rüber sprechen. Dann ist ja die Überraschung kaputt. Das soll eine Überraschung sein. Ja, gut, ich meine, woran wollen Sie jetzt im Haus, wenn mir das Geschenk nicht gefällt, unsere Rückgabe? Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich meine, Sie haben ja Erfahrung, Sie sind ja wahrscheinlich schon zu Ihren guten 20, 30 Jahren im Business. Was Sie für Erfahrungen gemacht haben, ob das bei älteren Damen häufiger auf Ablehnung schlägt? Nein, ich habe damit so gesehen keine Erfahrung, weil die Leute, die zu uns kommen und die sowas kaufen, die wissen, dass sie sowas wollen. Und das sind Kunden, die wirklich sich umfassend in der Regel im Internet so ein Punkt haben. Aber dass jemand sagt, ich möchte sowas eigentlich nicht haben, aber ich kaufe trotzdem... Also die Leute, die zu uns, die wollen es ja haben. Also Sie würden sagen, Sie würden mir von einem Geschenk eher abraten. Das ist ein zu grosses Risiko. Das habe ich damit nicht gesagt, das müssen Sie für sich alleine entscheiden. Na gut, aber wenn es nicht oft als Geschenk gekauft wird, hat das ja seinen Grund, nehme ich mal an. Der beste Verkäufer. Das habe ich nicht gesagt. Ich sage, ich rufe keine Erfahrung damit, ob das als Geschenk dann vielleicht auch nicht gut ankommt. Vielleicht ein Gutschein. Vielleicht hat er ja der Ehemann dann schon vorgefühlt oder so. Einen Gutschein können Sie natürlich von uns kommen. Ein Gutschein ist natürlich immer ein sehr langweiliges Geschenk. Ich will ja auch, dass die Mutter was zu spielen hat an Weihnachten. Ja, wo ist denn Ihre Mutter zu Hause? Auf dem Land. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig tatsächlich. In welcher Stadt? In Brunsbüttel. Ja, okay, das sind natürlich von uns. Ich meine, wenn Sie mal ins Auto packen wollen, gut, dann ist die Überraschung wieder erinnern, aber Brunsbüttel und natürlich bis zu uns fast 300 Kilometer. Ach, Sie meinen, dass man die Fahrt zu Ihnen auch schon als Überraschung verkauft? Da könnte ich Ihnen jetzt sagen, wir fahren irgendwo anders hin, in die Therme schön, und dann fahren wir eigentlich zu Ihnen. Genau. Da werden die Augen, glaube ich, gross sein. Und dann suchst du dich bei uns einen Sessel aus. Könnten Sie dann auch da so ein bisschen für eine Überraschung sorgen, also dass man dann so ein bisschen den Geschenkfaktor dann irgendwie schon da vorzieht, dass dann heisst Überraschungen, wenn du so ein Tuch hat über dem Sessel. Irgendwie so ein Tuch, Luftballons oder sowas. Ginge das so ein bisschen eventmässig? Nein, nein. Wir sind reiner Versender, wir machen das im sehr grossen Stil, bei uns gehen jeden Tag zig Sessel raus. Wie viele gehen denn bei Ihnen raus? Soll das jetzt ein Witz sein oder was? Wie viele Sessel wollen wir vom Park rausgehen? Wie viele Einkommen Sie auf einen Euro genau im Monat verliehen? Nein, um Gottes willen, so weit das nicht gemeint ist, würde mich nur interessieren, weil ich den gemeinen Massagesessel als nicht so verbreitet ansehe. Ich dachte, das wäre eigentlich eher ein exotisches Gut. Irgendwie bei, verstehen Sie, Sparfe bin ich jetzt nicht, oder? Nein, überhaupt nicht, nein, nein. Steigen lassen soll oder so? Nein, überhaupt nicht. Sie kennen das ja, irgendwie Weihnachten kommt immer näher und ich will natürlich irgendwas meine Oma suchen, aber es soll halt auch was Schönes sein. Ja, also Sie können gerne nach der Nienabschwache bei uns in der Firma vorbeikommen, aber Luftballon lasse ich da nicht steigen und mache auch keinen Konfetti und solche Geschichten. Aber Sie würden sich jetzt zum Beispiel über einen Massagesessel freuen, wenn ich Ihnen den jetzt schenken würde? Ich würde mich nicht freuen, weil ich habe schon zwei zu Hause und habe jeden Tag 40 bei mir in der Firma in der Ausstellung stehen. Okay, verstehe. Aber jetzt, wenn Sie sich mal ausüben, wenn Sie mal, Sie sind irgendwie ein Meeresbiologe oder sowas und haben nichts mit Massagesetten zu tun, würden Sie sich dann trotzdem noch wieder freuen? Ich würde jetzt eigentlich gerne mal auflegen, weil die Fragerei ist mir langsam ein bisschen zu blöd, ehrlich. Okay, Sie haben ja die Fragen auch bei... Also, es gibt ganz viele Anbieter für Massage, also rufen Sie bitte da an und fragen da. Wunderbar, vielen Dank für die Hilfe. Kennen Sie denn die Dame, die uns hier weiter verbunden hat? Bitte? Die Dame, mit der wir erst gesprochen haben, kennen Sie die? Ich, ähm, sag mal, ich lege jetzt das mal auf, ja. Okay, gut, vielen Dank, schöne, frohe Weihnachten. Meine Herren, was ist das denn für ein Laden? Was ist das denn für ein Scheissladen, ey? Was ist das Einstellungskriterium? Chronisch schlechte Laune. Was ist das denn für ein Laden? Aber das ist ein Scheissverkäufer. Das ist wirklich ein Scheissverkäufer. Das muss man echt mal sagen. Massagesessel. Ja. Und solche Leute tragen nicht dazu bei, dass Massagesessel ein besseres Bild in der Öffentlichkeit haben. Stopp doch mal! Will die dann laut werden? Ich verstehe es auch irgendwie, dass die Frage reinnervt. Aber ich habe mich tatsächlich falsch verhanden, weil wenn jemand laut wird, muss man auch laut. Das ist draußen neben dem Auto gestartet. Da kommen sie schon. Aber fand ich auch, der sagt, ja, da fahren sie die die zu uns, na gut dann ist die Überraschung natürlich auch weg, da hat er recht. Er hat mitgedacht, supergut. Wenn man achteinhalb Stunden im Auto sitzt, fragt die Oma schon mal, ja wo fahren wir denn jetzt hin und dann kann man schlägt sagen, Überraschung. Wenn man Glück hat, schlägt sie ein oder ist noch von Silvester so ein bisschen, ein bisschen angezündet, noch vom Morphium aus dem Krankenhaus, ein bisschen betäuft. Ich muss mal echt sagen, er hat einen Pfiffigen am Apparat, wo er auch meinte, wo er mitgedacht hat, da können sie die mitbringen zu uns. Genau, lösungsorientiert. Obwohl es so ein Versand ist, bringen sie die mit her und wir machen da was und dann kann sie sich das angucken und dann am Ende ist er so abgedriftet. Der Meeresbiologe war zu viel. War zu viel? Ja, ich... Ah, scheiße. Aber da war es eh schon gefallen, das Gespräch, glaube ich. Ich glaube, das war der Mann von der Frau, die uns verbunden hat. Nein, aber die erste Frau war doch wesentlich jünger. Ich kann extrem schlecht Alter schätzen. Wie alt war der denn jetzt? Der war doch um die 50, oder? Er war 52. Und Sie? 42. 42, hätte ich wesentlich jünger geschehen. Echt? Ja, unter 30 sogar. Nein, da kam dieser Oberlehrerton.
Na gut, aber als Hotline-Typ, wenn du mal fünf Jahre in einer Hotline sitzt, hast du da auch schon einen gewissen Ton drauf und weißt, wie du mit den Leuten umgehen musst. Das war so eine Frau, der läuft in der Ehe nicht mehr ganz so gut. Die hat schon angefangen, die hat schon angefangen. Wird es hier sexistisch? Nein, die hat angefangen. Da wird es ein bisschen sexistisch. Nein, nein, nein, bei dem Mann läuft auch in der Ehe nicht so gut. Aber bei ihr, da kommt schon jeden Abend so ein kleiner, so ein Giesse sich ein, so ein Chantree oder so rein. Kleine Jährweise vom Aldi. Sie befürchtet, dass der Mann auch irgendwie auswärts ein bisschen aktiver ist als bei ihr. Ich verstehe schon. Ich glaube, ich verstehe, was du meinst. Ja, ich will es jetzt nicht sagen. Wir kennen unsere Zielgruppe noch gar nicht. Das stimmt. Wir haben ja über Facebook die Möglichkeit, genau zu analysieren, wer unseren Podcast hört und wer nicht. Und da werden wir uns natürlich auch genau auf die Zielgruppe einlassen und gucken, wer hört uns denn und was braucht denn diese Zielgruppe. Wie läuft eigentlich, wir haben für drei Euro einen Beitrag bei Facebook. Genau, wir haben für Facebook Werbung gemacht für unseren ersten Post. Wie läuft es dabei? Ich gucke mal, wir haben einen Post gemacht, man kann bei Facebook, Facebook ist ja eigentlich die totale Abzocke, und zwar, wenn man jetzt eine Seite hat mit tausend Likes und man postet was, dann erscheint das nicht bei allen tausenden der Timeline, sondern nur bei manchen davon. Und wenn man möchte, dass es bei einer der Timeline erscheint, dann muss man tatsächlich zahlen. Und man kann natürlich auch durch diese Zahlen über die Like-Zahl hinaus Reichweite gewinnen.
Und genau das haben wir gemacht. Wir haben Werbung geschaltet vor unseren ersten Post. Und die Leute rasten aus. Sie haben 16 Gefällt mir Angaben. Rasten aus. Und zwar habe ich drei Euro eingegeben, und zwar zwei Euro 80 sind noch übrig. Also es wurde schon für 20 Cent Werbung geschaltet. Kann man das abbrechen und die zwei Euro80 Euro wieder bekommen? Geht das? Ich weiss nicht, das könne schon sein. Und zwar, wir haben, man sieht da genau, paid reach, wir haben dafür gezahlt, dass 63 Leute unseren Post sehen, davon hat einer das Bild angeklickt. 63 Leute. Also man kann sagen, es läuft. Genau, man muss schon reden, wenn ich was sage. Nein, ich habe eine Frage gestellt, die war zurück, fertiggestellt, ich habe gesehen, du musst husten, aber ich dachte, ich lasse ihn einfach jetzt mal leiden. Naja, nicht wir leiden, das Publikum leidet. Wenn wir nicht sagen, leidet das Publikum, dann sitzt er. Da ist keiner mehr dran, obwohl die, die waren heiß, die beiden Anrufe waren heiß. Die beiden Anrufe waren heiß, sollen wir die ja ganz am Anfang stellen. Die sollten wir ganz am Anfang erstellen. Ganz am Anfang stellen und dann ergibt es gesamte. Oder konstant im Hintergrund, immer im Hintergrund so leise laufen. Doch natürlich, die lief schon. Ach so, lief halt, ah. Ja, am Anfang, Intro, das müssen wir ja nicht extra ankündigen. Das war ja so ein fett Neffekt. Ich meine, wie Harald Lesch sagen würde, die unendlichen Weiten des Universums, man weiss nicht, was kommt, und Mathematik ist eine Hilfe für die Menschen. Und hier ist Harald Lesch, präsentiert in einer Imitation von Florentin Will. Herzlich willkommen, liebe Kinder, hört euch meine Sendung an, ihr lesst Kosmos, ich zeige euch die Welt. Ich habe mir tatsächlich deutlich mal nach Interstellar, einem Film bin ich sehr... Oh Gott, wir haben uns schon so lange im Interstellar getestet. Nein, ein Superfilm, muss man sagen, sieht Thorin auch so. Ein Furchtbarer Film. Nee, Furchtbar ist ein nicht guter Film. Nee, aber ich finde die Thematik interessant, die es anschneidet. Ja, und dafür ist der Film noch nicht gut. Sklaverei ist auch ein gutes Thema, deswegen ist trotzdem 12 Years a Slave ein schlechter Film. Sklaverei ist ein Ankommen. Mochte ich auch nicht. Und man muss sagen, da habe ich mir Videos angeguckt von Harald Lesch, wie er den Film quasi erklärt. Oh, das gibt's wirklich? Nein, er erklärt die Relativitätstheorie und so. Ah ja, verstehe. Ist ja ganz interessant. Ja, okay. Ja, natürlich ist Physik interessant. Ist auch ein Partythema. Ja, aber darum geht es doch nicht. Es geht darum, ob der Film gut ist oder nicht. Ja, aber die Thematik ist anscheinend, ist halt wirklich gut. Soll ich mal... Oder wie Matthew McConaughey in dem Film sagt, wir müssen in die tiefenen Weiten des Weltraums und wir müssen die Menschheit retten. Ne, so redet er doch, oder? Wie heißt die Schauspielerin nochmal? Ähm, ähm, ähm. Warte, warte, warte. Anne Hathaway. Anne Hathaway hat nämlich auch diesen tollen, die sind tollen, die erhielten. Die Liebe ist der wichtigste Baustein der Menschheit und wir können zwar viel verstehen. Wir fliegen durch Wurmlöcher und schwarze Löcher, aber wir wissen nicht, was Liebe ist. Und am Ende war ja wirklich die Message, dass sie von Anfang hätten auf die Liebe hören sollen. Naja, Matt Damon verrät sie, oh Spoiler, Matt Damon verrät sie ja. Mit einer tollen Rolle des Dr. Mann, der männlichste Name der Welt. Doktor Man, vor allem das ist ja wahrscheinlich wieder irgendeine Metapher, er heisst Doktor Man und steht für die ganze Menschheit. So wie John Nader irgendwie in der Lippen. Das ist ganz schön billig. Egal, das wird ein bisschen zu nerdig, wir sind ja auch keine Filmfreaks. Ist das ein Filmpodcast? Wir haben uns noch nicht festgelegt. Was ist das eigentlich? Ich würde mal sagen, wir machen auf jeden Fall einen Podcast über Dinge, mit denen wir uns auskennen. Und deswegen meine vierte Frage an Stefan Titze. Womit kennst du dich richtig gut aus? Ich kenne mich aus. Mit Dingen, mit denen ich mich gerade befasse. Ich bin nämlich so ein Mensch, ich habe für einen kurzen Zeitraum... Sehr kurzes Gedächtnis. Genau. Ich habe immer Interessen für kurze Dauer. Also sagen wir mal, für einen Monat habe ich andere Interessen. Ja, kenne ich gut. Ja, okay. Ich interessiere mich immer für einen Monat ungefähr für etwas sehr stark. Im Moment ist es tatsächlich so, Interstellar. Diese Astronomie finde ich ganz interessant. Also ich gucke mir dann gerne 24 Dokus an. Natürlich, ich arbeite ja auch. Aber du kratzt nur an der Oberfläche. Aber klar, immer. Wie ein Keyboard. Ich weiss, über alles bilde ich mir ein. Ein bisschen Bescheid, aber nichts richtig. Wie ein Keyboard? Wie ein Keyboard. Ich kann alles ein bisschen, aber nichts richtig. Das ist ein Keyboard, was? Das war mein Catchphrase. Es kann auch alles ein bisschen. Es kann halt mal ein bisschen Saxophon, aber nichts richtig. Und so geht es mir auch. Ich kann viele Dinge, ich habe immer gehört, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube viele Dinge, ich habe vieles mal gehört, aber es ist nichts, von dem man sagen kann. Du hast ein sehr gut ausgebildetes Halbwissen. Genau, aber das ist auch ein sehr gefährliches. Du hast ein doppeltes Halbwissen. Und ich behaupte immer Dinge, die nicht wahr sind. Verstehe. Von denen ich aber behaupte, dass sie wahr sind. Und ich vergesse oft von meinen Phasen, ich hatte früher immer zum Beispiel eine Dino-Phase oder eine Mittelalter-Phase, von diesen Dingen vergesse ich die meisten Sachen wieder. Ah, verstehe. So dass ich dann am Ende immer nur noch wirklich... Aber du bist generell immer interessiert. Ja, oft in Dinge, ich kann mich sehr gut für Dinge begeistern, auch für das Podcast-Sufo kann ich mich gerade begeistern. Könnt ihr euch auch für das Podcast-Sufo interessieren? Dann schreibt es in die Kommentare. Es gefällt mir so sehr, dieses Moderative, dieses... Aber deswegen hätte ich auch so gerne Musik. Tatsächlich, ich finde, in Radiosendungen ist Musik immer saunervig. Das wollten wir nicht erwähnen. Das sollten wir nicht erwähnen. Und schon in der ersten Folge hast du da jedenfalls gestossen. Ich piep's raus. Ich ersetze sowas anderes.
Sorg und sanft fertig.
Zum Beispiel bei die Radio-Fritzen finde ich es immer total nervig, wenn die Musik kommt.
Ich finde, das ist ein total richtig guter Reiz.
Aber es ist ein super guter Trenner.
Oh, geil.
Es ist gut, um Themen abzustrennen.
Wenn da die Musik kommt, ich höre immer den Podcast und höre ich die Musik nicht, die wird rausgeschnitten,
aber man hört immer, und jetzt kommt Anne Hathaway mit Can't Live Without You.
So, und das ist immer total geil, weil das hat immer so eine Struktur.
Und das anzukündigen, hat so etwas Professionelles, und das finde ich immer total geil, wenn wir jetzt einfach sagen sollen, so, wir müssen uns zu Musik kommen, hier ist Ronin Keating mit Life is a Rollercoaster, bis gleich.
Einfach, wenn man so etwas machen würde, das ist total cool.
Und das machen wir auch. Und du hast ein bisschen gesagt, wir passen ein paar Safcar. Du solltest an einer Pass-Fascar-Parodie arbeiten.
Ach so, wie Fake it till you make it, oder was, dass man einfach immer ankündigt, jetzt kommt Werbung. So, jetzt kommt erstmal ein bisschen Werbung undst du, wie sagst du das? Refrain. Ach Gott. Was ich zum Beispiel auch unmöglich aussprechbar finde, ist, also, wie heissen zum Beispiel diese kleinen, äh, wie heissen zum Beispiel diese kleinen zuckrigen Stücke, die man in den Mund steckt und dann lutscht und es schmeckt gut, wie heissen die? Bonbons. Bonbons. Bonbons. Bonbons. Bonbons. Bonbons. Buchstabier das mal. Also in Lautschrift? Ja, wie das aussprichst. B-O-N-G, B-O-N-G. Bonbon. Bonbon. Bonbon. Ich sag nicht Bonbon. So wie die Stadt, Bonbon. Köln-Bonbon. Wie sagst du's? Bonbon. es ist eher so ein B-O-M-B-O-N-G.
Bom-Bon-Bon.
Bonbon.
Aber wirklich, wenn man sich da mal darauf konzentriert, ich kann dieses Wort…
Es ist wohl, es heisst ein Bonbon bei mir.
B-O-M-B-O-N-G ist bei mir.
Bonbon.
Listen and repeat.
Ich kann das mittlerweile nicht mehr sagen, weil mich macht das so paranoid, weil ich
nicht weiss, wie das… Bonbon ist natürlich zu viel, aber Bonbon oder Bonbon ist natürlich zu viel. Wir haben hier so eine Soundwand aus, was ist, Filz, Schaumfilz. Ja, so aus Polstergeschichten. Du darfst nicht auf den Computer kommen, sonst hört die Aufnahme auf. Nehmen wir schon auf übrigens. Sollen wir jetzt mal anfangen aufzunehmen? Du hast dich gerade verraten, dass du sagst, aufhören, die dann pausen. Nehmen wir immer noch auf. Ich habe auch wieder auf den Shop gekommen, glaube ich. Was ich zum Beispiel auch interessant finde, ist, wie heißt denn dieses Zeug, dass man sich auf den Körper sprüht, um besser zu riechen? Deo. Nein, das andere. Parfum. Parfum. Nee, jetzt habe ich jetzt nur gesagt, weil du es genau so sagen. Du wirst, wenn du Refrain sagst, hast du auch Parfum. Parfum. Ich sage Parfüm. Naja gut, aber es gibt ja Parfüm, dann gibt es das Möchtegern-Französische, Parfum, Parfum. Oder Toilette. Parfum sagt man dann, Parfum, oder man sagt wirklich Französisch Parfum, Parfum, Parfum. So, als hätte man auch so drei Zigaretten gerade im Mund. Parfum, Parfum, Parfum. Aber man kann ja, College Humor hat da tatsächlich gerade einen guten Sketch rausgebracht über jemanden, der immer alles richtig sagt. Und der sagt, bring mir doch mal das Croissant, der halt dann ist auch wirklich oder irgendwie ein bisschen Gelato oder sowas, wo man immer die Fremdwörter richtig betont. Wir fallen jetzt im Deutschen nicht so viel ein, aber Croissant zum Beispiel oder Taco, Friseur, aber gut, ich glaube, das Thema hat sich erschöpft. Ich glaube, unser Gast aus. Wahnsinnig. Vielen Dank, dass du heute da warst. Sind wir echt durch? Jan Böhmann war heute bei uns. Wir haben eine Stunde geredet. Ja, Jan Böhmann war heute bei uns. Vielen Dank, dass du dabei warst im Studio. Ah, Handshake und ansonsten. Ach, das war unser Gag, den wir uns vorher ausgedacht haben. Ja, das war einer der vielen Gags, die wir uns vorher ausgedacht haben, aber da nicht durchgezogen haben. Dass im Studio gerade einer sitzt. Die Grumpy Cat war heute da. Ach nee, die kommt nächste Woche. Nächste Woche kommt die Grumpy Cat, freut euch darauf. Wenn ihr Fragen habt an die Grumpy Cat, dann schreibt sie doch in die Kommentarspalte von unserer Facebook-Seite oder unter Twitter bei Twitter mit dem Hashtag PodcastUFO. Ansonsten wünschen wir euch noch eine schöne Woche. Bis zum nächsten Mal, bleibt dran, empfehlen uns weiter und abonniert uns auf iTunes und gebt uns für gute Bewertungen, liked unsere Seite auf Facebook, das Podcast UFO oder folgt uns auf Twitter.
Dankeschön.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Macht's gut.
Tschüss, wir heben ab.